Yes. Well, I'm not sure I really need the miles.
[inaudible] you? We do break. So let's take this off. Where did that come from?
I made it myself. So it's unique.
I suppose I've always felt it's quite difficult to do unique things with the
periodic table,
but I wanted to tell you about something else that I did,
which I thought was unique as well with the periodic table.
What very nice segue professor.
It started a long time before, um,
locked down perhaps nearly five years ago.
I was playing on my computer one afternoon and decided,
I can't remember why to flip the horizontal of the periodic
table using PowerPoint.
So what was pointing up suddenly pointed down and it was a sort of
joke. But then when I looked at it,
I was really quite surprised because the periodic table
turned out to look something like this. Of course, the first time I did it,
the letters weren't the right way round.
I thought it was good if you thought about the periodic table, like a graph,
because when it's a graph, if you have the zero here,
things normally increase in this direction and that one,
then the periodic table, they increase in this direction,
but everything like weight and so on increases when you get it downwards.
So it's a bit sort of upside down. And this is really difficult.
When we talk to chemists to our students about how the
electrons fill up to give you the structure of the periodic table.
It's got a German name, it's called the outbound principle,
meaning the building up principle.
Somehow it doesn't sound good to the students.
If you say this means building up and then you do it downwards.
So I got quite excited about this and I wrote a little article about
how having the periodic table, the other way up might be better.
Certainly from the point of view of teaching. And I wrote to, um,
an expert on the periodic table and said,
had he ever seen one like this? And he said, no.
So I got really excited.
Perhaps I'd done something new with the periodic table.
So I sent it to the journal and the editor was quite excited.
But then he said, hang on a minute.
Perhaps people will read it like a book from the left to the right and
starting at the top rather than the bottom,
where all the interesting elements like hydrogen and helium are,
and they'll concentrate too much on the heavy elements at the top.
So we were stuck.
And then I suddenly remembered that my daughter,
who's an experimental psychologist who specializes in
measuring where people look tracking their eyes when they look at the picture.
And so they could see whether I was looking at Brady or the camera,
whatever I decided I would collaborate with her,
never collaborated with my daughter before in the scientific project.
So she entered colleague Alexis set up an experiment,
not a very big one with 24 subjects so that people weren't
biased. They used a blank periodic table with all the squares,
but not the letters. And the results were really quite surprising.
What they found was that if you look at an ordinary
periodic table,
you begin by looking in the middle and then your eyes go to the top where
hydrogen and helium are. But with the inverted periodic table,
you still begin in the middle,
but your eyes gives downwards to the hydrogen and helium.
So we could prove to the editor
that the way people looked at our periodic table was different from a book.
Why is that professor does, does the paper,
or did your daughter conclude why no matter where you put those elements,
hydrogen and helium and you know, the well that's where you go.
Kids because the picture, well,
the periodic table is relatively symmetrical where
the lanthanides and active for nights and heavy elements are,
but at the bottom or the top, depending on which one you're looking at,
where hydrogen helium are, they're a bit unsymmetrical.
And I think your eye is drawn to things that are unsymmetrical.
And there was also thought that perhaps the upside
down periodic table looked a bit like an animal with legs. Um,
but that wasn't really proved one way or another.
The numbers were significant,
but the difference wasn't huge,
but it was enough to convince us. And more importantly,
the editor and the referee. So the tip was a real effect.
And if you're interested,
you can read all the details in the supplementary information,
the paper,
there was then quite a long delay because chemistry journal
had never published a paper involving human subjects.
And there was a lot of extra paperwork, but it was published.
And I was really excited to have a paper with my name
and Ellen's name together.
Oppressor Bay on us. Cause it's just you, me and the periodic videos.
Viewers was this bit of like a gimmick or a publicity stunt, or what,
what are you trying to achieve here?
You're not seriously trying to get every table on a wall and a textbook in the
world, flipped upside down. Yeah.
What I wanted to do was to make people think differently about the periodic
table.
I am showered by people sending me different sorts of the
periodic table saying theirs is much better than the conventional one
and so on. I don't think I was any better than any other one,
but for some purposes like explaining the filling of the electron shells could
be useful. There was some quite exciting things.
The New York times and the London times wrote little
articles about it.
Never had my research in the popular press before.
And then it caused quite a sensation in Japan
and a museum in Japan included the version of the periodic table
in their display for the international year of the periodic table.
And best of all,
for the closing ceremony of the international year of the periodic table in
Tokyo, a special fan was made.
You can see it here quite useful on the whole day and which
has a upside down periodic table on it.
But the really important lesson for me
was that you cannot really do anything very original
with the periodic table.
And sometime after the people was published,
somebody pointed out to me that the English theoretical chemist
Christopher longer tigons had published a paper in
1957 when I was nine years old, not quite 10,
and that never heard of the periodic table saying perhaps it would be
better to have the periodic table the other way round for teaching the output
principle. In the end,
I got the fun of publishing a paper by got quite a solitary
lesson that you cannot discover anything new about the
periodic table,
except if you're Brady who invented the periodic
table of videos, which I think really was originally.
If you've ever dreamed of having your name on the periodic table. Well,
I'm not sure there's much we can do to help you with that.
That's a very select club, some of the great names in science,
but what you can do is have your name on our periodic table of patrons,
which looks like this. This is a slightly less exclusive,
but equally important club of people that support our project on Patrion.
We update this table every month or two with names of people who've adopted
elements,
Patrion supporters also receive occasional exclusive extras photos behind the
scenes stuff. If you're interested,
go to patrion.com/periodic videos,
or have a look at the links I've put in the video description.
Thanks everyone for watching.
We'll be back again soon with more stories from the periodic table. That one,
not the Patriot on one.